its volume equals one-third the area of
the base times the height so when you
see that capital b it means the area of
the bottom
times the height now you don't want to
get confused when you do surface area
you're using the slant height you can
it's usually used um the letter l for
the slant height that's the angled
height or the leaning height here we
want the
perpendicular height the perpendicular
distance from the center of the base
to the vertex here that's the overall
height okay same thing with the cone
we're going from the center of the base
okay perpendicular to the the vertex
right there okay so let's go ahead and
do this example of the pyramid now one
thing i wanted to show you is that if
you put this pyramid okay in a box
okay like this
okay can you visualize this here
if you put it in a box
this pyramid would only take up a third
of the volume of that box so if the
bases were the same the height was the
same because of the pyramid is like you
know on a diagonal it's angled up okay
like this you could actually fit two
more of these pyramids in there granted
you have to cut them up or you know
divide them up somehow so that they
would you know fit in all those empty
spaces there so this is only taking up a
third that's where you can see the
thirds coming from there but let's go
ahead and do this so it's volume equals
one-third
okay area of the base now the base here
you can see is a square so it's going to
be eight times eight so that's 64
times the overall height so we don't
want this height here sometimes we'll
give you this okay we don't want that
one we want 10
and so there you go so it's one-third
times 64 times 10 that's going to give
your volume and that's going to be in
units cubed
okay the next one
is a cone okay so a cone it's exact same
formula i like to kind of group my
formulas together like this so there's
less to memorize and you might want to
do the same thing too so cones and
pyramids kind of have the same shape
right just a different kind of a base so
you just have to think okay this is a
circle what's the area of a circle
pi r squared okay so that's the base
right there
times the height and we want this
perpendicular height not the slant
height okay the radius is 5
so we have pi times 5 squared so that's
pi times 25
times 1 3
times the height which is 10.
so if you multiply all that together
that's going to give you your volume in
units cubed now just a quick note
sometimes students get a little bit
you know tripped up on the fractions you
can think of any whole number as a
fraction by putting it over one so you
would multiply all the numerators all
the denominators and then you would
divide so in this case that's 25 times
10 is 250 times pi so that's 250 pi
if we want an exact answer if you want
to round an answer just use 3.14 for pi
and then 3 times 1 times 1 times 1 is 3
and there you go that's an exact answer
but again you could
make pi 3.14 divide get a decimal and
round but this is exact